[Music]
sure you've been here before well yes
but have you ever had a personal tour
from the director of the western art
galleries
no
there is this crucial scene where we the
audience meet the three characters
together for the first time in the 1950s
in Brighton Museum and art gallery
obviously there are a lot of
complexities with the dynamic between
the three of them when they're all
together
taste is simply just knowing how
something makes you feel
so how does it make you feel it's an
Exquisite scene because it also is the
scene that is is part of this dual
timeline we think it's a scene where Tom
is introducing Marion to somebody he's
met we do not know that actually Patrick
and Tom have already been there so we
follow the narrative in what we think is
real time
[Music]
when Tom arranges to meet Patrick in the
gallery he finds a painting himself and
Patrick doesn't take him to a painting
and what he stands in front of is a
storm at sea
can sense the waves
you know how strong they are
like swimming in rough surf
exciting
and frightening Tom is just really
curious and wants to learn and I think
that's really refreshing to meet someone
who is Young and from a working class
background and wants to learn about art
and go to museums what strikes
Patrick about Tom what attracts Patrick
to Tom is that he's his complete
opposite I think that fascinates him and
a little later in time Tom goes back to
the gallery but with Marion
notice the light
striking the crest of the crashing waves
[Music]
feel they could crush
trick describes the painting to Marion
as Tom described the painting to Patrick
when he saw it the first time it has a
different meaning later slightly as
there's the meaning of like oh if
actually she was on this tour the two of
them already knew each other so that's
why it plays out from her point of view
is her fascination
that particular scene is shot in two
locations of the exteriors were shot
down in Brighton and the interior is the
Wallace collection in central London
okay technically shooting at a museum
where there are Priceless works of art
on the wall it's quite a challenge you
can't rig any sort of lighting
instruments you're pushing around large
pieces of equipment next to Priceless
works of art
it's difficult
the reason we chose the wall is
collection was it had a lovely sense of
natural light as these two glass sort of
vaulted roof at the top and so I liked
it for that because it's stacked with
paintings it almost became slightly
claustrophobic it acted as something
where it pushed them all into an
environment together
because everyone is looking at the
paintings you get this wonderful idea
where you can frame a shop with a three
of the minute and they can all be
thinking and doing a different thing
Blake's trying to start all the senses
as well as the spirit there's so much
passion in his work the Blake painting
we chose because it creates something of
Abandonment it creates something of
Freedom it creates something of
friendship
there are moments in it where you see
Marion looking at Patrick and you think
oh there's there's an attraction there
then there's Tom who's in between the
two of them and you kind of see his
dilemma we wanted to try and suggest the
audience that actually it might be
Marion and Patrick who end up together
point is something is going on Marion is
responding to this because actually a
little bit of her is being opened up in
the most extraordinary way you see that
in Emma's performance
is one of my favorite paintings raising
of Lazarus by Yan Levins Jan leaving's
Lazarus picture we found this painting
and thought that's a good that is
something that one could believe Patrick
would be in order of Marion immediately
sees something in it
is also a painting about a rebirth
and about two friends and one of them
coming alive again and somewhere in
there there is a story that Patrick Is
Telling Tom they're talking in code
through talking about art and um they're
talking about themselves and they're
talking about the world they're
currently living in I wouldn't mind
learning more about paintings
art I mean
well that's admirable
is it why
because a man should always try to
improve himself
it's particular and important
environment the color of your walls if
you can't change them in a location and
as someone who's
very interested in color I want
obviously all those colors had to be in
balance
for the Tom character he's he's out of
his depth in that environment he wants
to fit in so you know he wears a smart
shirt and a tie and tries to look as
grown up as he can Patrick uh his his
thematic color is this mustard there's
flecks of mustard in that soup he has
this important role in the museum and we
decided that he got all his suits made
at a tailors in Brighton not German
Street in London lightwise Marion I
think her ability to make artistic
choices is evident but it's still quite
sort of conservative in a sense I wanted
everyone to look in Harmony in that
environment that's why I went for that
particular burgundy she helped us
understand more about Marion helped us
understand more about Tom off duty
foreign
this scene was probably the one that I
scored the most different ways
[Music]
my first attempt at it was very much
about Patrick it was all Patrick
presenting something in the arrival in
their lives of this more flamboyant kind
of character and then that kind of
started to feel like we weren't sort of
really reflecting what was really going
on behind the scenes and then I tried
another version which was a much more
kind of excited version than it was a
much pacier thing and it felt like the
excitement of going to the museum in a
new life beginning
[Music]
and then what emerged then was this
version which stops and it starts and
it's it leaves lots of spaces for look
these little glances and looks between
people started to emerge to let the
audience realize that this wasn't just a
simple trip to the museum
the film could be opened up in so many
ways by coming at it from different
angles
that whole scene is constructed in a way
whereas you don't know what you're quite
seeing there yet what you think you're
seeing turns out to be something more
nuanced than that later and language
about the art is the start of the
language of their relationship
astonishing
exactly